hey everyone and welcome back to Simply
learns YouTube channel I hope you guys
are doing well and today we have an
exciting topic waiting for you how to
become a cloud architect in 2024 so if
you're looking for a career that's
Dynamic rewarding and at the Forefront
of Technology becoming a cloud architect
might be your perfect choice so stick
around as we break it all down for you
in this video by before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily and press that
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn also do check out the cloud
architect Masters program by simply
learn this program will help you build
your AWS Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform expertise from the ground
up you will learn to master the
architectural principles and services of
the top Cloud platform design and deploy
highly scalable fall tolerant
application ation and develop skills to
transform yourself into an AWS and asure
Cloud expert this program will give you
an in-depth understanding of cloud
services such as AWS cloud formation
Azure resource manager ec2 S3 Route 53
VPC Azure app services and gcp you'll
acquire the Knowledge and Skills for
passing Cloud architect certifications
such as AWS architect and Azure
architect candidates with one plus year
of work experience are preferred to
enroll in this program so check out the
link mentioned in the Des description
box below for more details so without
wasting any more time let's start this
video with what is cloud computing cloud
computing refers to the practice of
using remote servers on the internet to
store manage and process data instead of
relying solely on your local computer it
allows you to access your files
applications and services from anywhere
with an active internet connection
providing convenience scalability and
flexibility for individuals and
businesses alike moving ahead let's
discuss who is a cloud AR architect so a
cloud architect is a specialized IT
professional responsible for Designing
planning and overseeing the architecture
of cloud computing Solutions within an
organization they play a pivotal role in
translating business requirements into
technical specifications and ensuring
that the cloud infrastructure meet the
organization's scalability security
performance and cost Effectiveness goals
so why would you consider a career as a
cloud architect well there are many
reasons but here are a few that should
get you excited the first reason being
high demand the demand for cloud
Architects is skyrocketing as businesses
continue to shift their operations to
the cloud the need for experts who can
design build and maintain these Cloud
infrastructures will only increase
second let's talk about the paychecks
Cloud Architects are among the highest
paid Professionals in the IT industry
third if you love learning and staying
at The Cutting Edge of Technology Cloud
architecture is your playground Cloud
providers are constantly innovating
which means you'll have the chance wants
to learn and grow throughout your career
lastly Cloud architecture offers Global
opportunities the cloud Knows No
Boundaries whether you are in New York
Tokyo Sydney or Mumbai your skills will
be in demand worldwide so now let's go
through the road map to become a cloud
architect in
2024 the first step of this road map is
learning cloud fundamentals this is the
starting point for anyone aspiring to be
a cloud architect it involves
understanding the foundational concepts
of cloud computing such as
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service or pass and software as a
service or SAS learning about
virtualization cloud service models and
Cloud deployment model is also crucial
building a solid foundation in Cloud
fundamentals will give you the knowledge
base needed to progress the second step
of this road map is cloud platform
proficiency Cloud Architects are often
platform agnostic which means they need
to be proficient in multiple Cloud
platforms so get experience in Cloud
platform platforms like Amazon web
services Microsoft Azure and Google
Cloud platform this step involves
becoming comfortable with various cloud
services tools and ecosystems across
different Cloud providers the third step
of this road map is security expertise
security is Paramount in the world of
cloud
architecture understanding Cloud
security practices and compliance with
relevant regulations is essential you
need to know how to protect Cloud
systems data and applications from cyber
threats and
vulnerabilities learning about identity
and access management I am encryption
and compliance Frameworks is vital to
become a cloud architect in 2024 the
next step in this road map is
containerization containerization is a
key component of modern Cloud
architecture you should learn about
containerization Technologies like
Docker and container orchestration
platforms like kubes understanding how
to create deploy and manage
containerized applications is crucial
for scalability and flexibility in the
cloud the next step of this road map is
Automation and scripting automation
plays a pivotal role in Cloud
architecture learn scripting languages
like Python and automation tools
infrastructure as code tools like
terraform and ncble help automate the
provisioning and management of cloud
resources so let's move on to the sixth
step of this road map the next step is
devops and continuous integration and
continuous deployment Pipelines M ra
devops practices to bridge the gap
between development and operations
understand cicd pipelines which automate
application builds testing and
deployment devops and CD ensure
efficient agile and error-free software
delivery in the a cloud environment now
let's move on to the last and seventh
step of this road map Cloud architecture
patterns different Cloud architecture
patterns should be understo such as
microservices serverless and hybrid
clouds know when to use each pattern and
how to design system for scalability
performance and cost Effectiveness and
this is the road map you need to follow
in order to become a successful Cloud
architect in
2024 with the growing demand of cloud
Architects skilled professionals have
opportunity to boost their earnings by
enhancing their skills acquiring
Advanced education and gaining practical
experience so let's delve into the
critical skills required to become a
successful Cloud architect in 2024
enabling you to excel in a competitive
job market and negotiate more favorable
compensation so the first skill is
technical expertise Cloud Architects
must deeply understand Cloud platforms
infrastructure as code containerization
and other Cloud related Technologies
they must design deploy and manage Cloud
Solutions effectively making technical
expertise a Cornerstone of this rule the
second skill is problem solving Cloud
Architects frequently encounter complex
challenges and issues in Cloud
environments they need strong problem
solving skills to analyze these problems
and develop innovative solutions that
ensure Cloud systems functionality
security and efficiency the third skill
is adaptability the cloud landscape
continuously evolves with new tools
services and best practices Cloud
Architects must stay adaptable and open
to learning as keeping Pace with these
changes is essential to remain relevant
and effective in their roles and the
next step is communication effective
communication is crucial for cloud
Architects they must translate complex
technical Concepts into understandable
terms for non-technical stakeholders
including Business Leaders project teams
and other departments clear
communication ensures alignment between
Technical Solutions and business goals
and lastly soft skills Cloud Architects
collaborate with diverse teams including
developers operations and business units
effective teamwork leadership and basic
project management skills are essential
for successful Cloud projects these
skills enable Architects to lead
projects manage resources and drive them
to successful completion and and finally
it's time to talk about some money and
checks this job role has to offer to
aspiring Cloud
enthusiasts according to glaso the
average salary of a cloud architect
working in India goes around rupees 22
lakhs perom and in the United States it
goes around
$171,000 per enom with additional cash
compensation the salary figures of
course might change depending on the
skills you acquire and the company you
work for and with that we have come to
the end of this cloud architect roadmap
2024 I hope you found it valuable and by
now you should have a good understanding
of the steps you need to follow to
become a successful Cloud architect in
2024 so if you enjoyed watching this
video then do give it a thumbs up and
share it with your friends please ask
any question about the topics covered in
this video in the comments box below and
our team of experts will try to assist
you as soon as possible thank you so
much for being here today we'll see you
next time until then keep learning and
stay tuned to Simply learn for more
amazing updates staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here